pendant des années on nous a servi le
même discours
notre patrimoine disparaît et l'on parle
bien ici de seebach de ces bistrots où
se concentre la vie des villages depuis
peu on voit pourtant renaître de vieux
crépy comme ici à saint-aubin dans le
jura le bar a rouvert après quinze ans
de sommeil internet se retrouver c'est
vrai qu'il nous manquait il manque un
café à saint-aubin maintenant qu'il est
ouvert on est bien content je pense
qu'il va avoir du monde beaucoup de
monde dans le jura en 2010 on comptait
116 débits de boissons en 2010 750 sur
ce graphique on voit bien une envolée en
2015 alors que s'est il passé à
saint-aubin la mairie avait gardé la
licence iv mais elle a fait plus que
cela elle a racheté le bâtiment pour
quatre cent mille euros
un pari un peu effrayant pour le maire
de cette commune 2008 150 habitants et a
quand même eu des risques parce qu'ils
avaient plus de avait plus de clientèle
il n'y avait plus rien donc il a fallu
quand même moi j'ai eu le soutien de mes
collègues élus un pour eux pour
comprennent quand même le risque de
relancer ça aujourd'hui on ne le
regrette pas
tout roule on a du monde les gens jouent
le jeu la commune
satisfaite je suis satisfait on est
satisfait on a embauché
parmi les clients du bar certains
applaudissent comme le boulanger ravis
de trouver un allié tous ses repas et
nous prend le bain et nous verrons bien
manger de temps en temps avec toute
l'entreprise et puis tout le monde est
content à quelques kilomètres de là un
autre bar restaurant le patron voudrait
bien prendre sa retraite mais il met en
garde vaut le bord et puis autre chose à
côté
ou alors je vous dis faire des soirées à
thème pour faire un petit peu de
restauration
voilà c'est d'attirer les gens
réinventer la tradition du bistrot
n'empêche aujourd'hui dans le jura 9
communes sur dix n'ont plus de café